[Musique]
et voilà bonsoir pour ce nouveau stream
alors voilà j'arrive tout doucement à
maîtriser obs et a lancé le stream à
l'heure ça a été souvent le problème ces
dernières semaines mais il ya un truc
qui bug quand même chez chez youtube ou
en tout cas chez moi et je n'arrive pas
toujours à bien maîtriser la chose enfin
bon ça c'est du détail alors on se
retrouve dès comme chaque semaine pour
lire ensemble un article de sciences
sociales un article apparentés aux
sciences sociales un article
scientifique ou un article presque
scientifique ou en tout cas dans un
certain esprit scientifique
1 vous verrez qu'aujourd'hui encore on
va on va aborder un type d'article qu'on
n'avait pas encore abordé dans les
stream précédent alors si vous arrivez
pour la première fois sur sur cette
émission bien en fait sur la chaîne
youtube vous allez pouvoir revoir
l'ensemble des streams qu'on a déjà
réalisé ensemble avec de vulgarisation
d'articles scientifiques d'articles de
sciences sociales qui traitent de
différents domaines de différents
aspects des sciences sociales évidemment
je suis pas spécialiste dans tout mais
c'est l'idée de découvrir ensemble
et moi j'essaie de vous accompagner dans
la lecture de cet article la différentes
choses différentes publications liées
aux sciences sociales
pour être transparents avec vous le
choix des articles je fais comme une pré
sélection je propose trois articles au
vote je soumets ses articles sur
l'onglet communauté de youtube je vais
passer sur la fenêtre de travail et vous
allez directement voir
de quoi il s'agit donc sur la chaîne
youtube ici vous allez retrouver dans
cet onglet communauté vous allez
retrouver les différents articles que je
propose chaque semaine un donc voilà il
ya quand même un choix qui est possible
pour vous je vous propose déjà le choix
de la semaine prochaine il y aura le
capital culturel structure structure
t-il toujours les goûts alors on parle
vraiment du travail de pierre bourdieu
et de sons de l'importance finalement
qu'il donne au capital culturel si vous
n'êtes pas familier du travail de
bourdieu je vous renvoie sur la chaîne
sociologique la chaîne youtube
sociologie ou ici à une nouvelle vidéo
sur bourdieu qui a été réalisé qui est
vraiment sympa et qui est une bonne
synthèse finalement de toute la théorie
de bourdieu et donc vous saurez c'est
quoi exactement le capital culturel mais
aussi sur la société vous pouvez
retrouver différentes vidéos sur le
travail de pierre bourdieu
le deuxième choix de la semaine
prochaine ce sera l'urbanisation en
france la fin d'urbanisation en france
point d'interrogation donc là on va plus
faire la géographie mais moi comme je
suis aussi de la géographie belge en
janvier aussi parfois de vous en
proposer et puis l'héroïne sportive au
cinéma qui est ce que la femme quand
elle est une femme qui gagne au niveau
du sport qui est une compétitrice quel
est le type d'image que l'on propose et
qui est véhiculée par les productions
artistiques
donc voilà cdd des choix très différent
parce que j'essaie vraiment de proposer
dans différents domaines parfois je suis
un peu déçu je dois vous dire des choix
qui seront faits parce que moi j'aurais
choisi autre chose mais voilà c'est le
jeu c'est comme ça donc ça le vote sera
disponible dès demain vous pourrez voter
pour déjà dimanche prochain alors cette
semaine mais vous avez majoritairement
voté pour cet article 6 alors je dis
majoritairement parce que ça s'est joué
kifkif avec un offre un autre article
qui traitait de comment ça fonctionne à
l'elysée elysée c'est le bureau
présidentiel français ou lady saision
les décisions principales sont prises au
niveau du chef d'état mais ce n'est pas
celui-là qui a gagné c'est plutôt celui
ci un article qui parle de démographie
donc c'est bien c'est la première fois
qu'on va faire de la démographie dans ce
stream
sur youtube et sur twitch là puisqu'on
est en simultané sur youtube et sur
twitch je le rappelle est donc en fait
c'est une communication qui est un petit
peu spécial parce qu'en fait c'est issus
de la revue population et sociétés mais
qui est plus ou moins une revue c'est
plutôt un bulletin d'information et si
je vous mets le site de l'ined lynette
c'est un grand institut français
d'études démographiques vraiment il ya
vraiment beaucoup de données super
intéressante et des outils aux six mois
en tant que prof que j'utilise parfois
certains outils certains visualisation
qui sont permises par des graphiques ou
des représentations sur ce site de
l'ined mais sur ce site de lynette vous
trouvez aussi un bulletin d'information
scientifique donc c'est bien de niveau
scientifique de quatre pages ça va être
très très court aujourd'hui je vais
pouvoir vraiment tout lire parce que
voilà il n'y a pas tellement publié en
français en anglais ils traitent chaque
mois d'une thématique particulière
accessible au grand public et celle que
nous avons choisie ici elle traite des
migrations internationales
ce que l'on peut mesurer ce que l'on ne
peut pas mesurer et c'est un thème qui
est vraiment très intéressant parce que
dès qu'on aborde cette question avec les
élèves au cours de géographie puisque
c'est dans le programme par exemple
récent cinquième année ce qui équivalent
de la première en france eh bien les
élèves très justement pose la question
mais monsieur mais que qu'en est il de
la migration clandestine qui par
définition n'est pas contrôlée ni
vérifiée et donc voilà déjà ils ont déjà
une réflexion par rapport à ce phénomène
migratoire qui est très important
aujourd'hui puisqu'on dit que
l'émigration vont s'accélérer avec le
changement climatique et puis on a vu
avec l'actualité proche évidemment en
ukraine que ça a des conséquences
migratoires mais ça fait aussi écho à
court terme à la présidentielle
française
puisque deux candidats voire trois
candidats avec valérie pécresse sont
très portés sur les migrations et
fustige ces migrations en disant
vraiment qu elles sont excessives et
qu'il faudrait les réduire pour la
france donc voilà c'est vraiment un
choix qui est très actuel finalement à
plus d'un titre j'ai envie de dire à
moyens à court terme à moyen terme et à
long terme de bien se poser la question
de ce que sont les migrations et donc
j'insiste ici on n'est pas vraiment sur
un article qui va présenter une
recherche de sciences sociales c'est
plutôt vraiment une communication pour
préciser certains points
pour décrypter comment un phénomène est
mesuré plutôt que vraiment d'avoir un
travail une recherche qui va poser des
hypothèses qu qui elle-même repose sur
une problématique qui répond elle même à
une question de départ et ainsi de suite
et ainsi de suite donc là on est
vraiment sur quelque chose de tout à
fait différent donc comme je voulais dit
on va cette fois-ci tout lire alors je
tiens aussi à souligner que les tchats
que ce soit sur twitch ou sur youtube
sont à votre disposition
c'est toujours sympa d'intervenir ça
permet en tout cas sur twitch de rendre
la chaîne beaucoup plus visible mais sur
youtube aussi donc voilà si simplement
vous êtes là derrière votre écran et que
vous dites battre j'ai trop rien à dire
fait un petit coucou ça fera avancer la
chaîne et ça sera sympa voilà alors
c'est parti mon kiki parmi les
événements qui contribuent à la
dynamique démographique les migrations
sont les plus difficiles à appréhender
au contraire des naissances et des décès
elles font l'objet de définition
variable selon les pays et de mesures
beaucoup moins standardisés deux
facteurs de confusion dans les débats
publics crise beauchemin louise caron
marina date et franck temporal font le
point sur le sujet et situe la france
par rapport à ses pays voisins alors si
vous êtes belge puisque cette chaîne
s'adresse à la fois
bien aux personnes qui s'intéressent aux
sciences sociales en france mais aussi
en belgique et pourquoi pas dans toute
la francophonie bon ben voilà c'est
souvent des des articles qui parlent de
la réalité française que je sélectionne
parce que le principal public est
d'abord français mais vous verrez que
dans cet article on va aussi parler de
la belgique d'eau qu'il faut pas
s'inquiéter ça ne parle pas que de la
france même si
l'accès plus tôt pour traiter les
migrations en france mais on verra aussi
les chiffres pour la belgique
alors autre chose je vais déjà un petit
peu explicite et on leur dira dans le
corps de l'article mais c'est peut-être
intéressant d'insister là dessus en fait
quand vous parlez de démographie il n'y
a pas trente six mille phénomène de base
à appréhender il ya bien sûr ces
migrations et puis tout simplement les
naissances et les décès bon dans les
états modernes généralement les
naissances et les décès
on sait plus ou moins correctement les
mesures et puisque il ya tout un service
administratif qui prend les naissances
qui actent les décès dans nos pays voilà
vous devez déclarer votre enfant si vous
en avez un vous devez déclarer les décès
dans votre entourage si vous en
connaissez
donc tout ça est comptabilisée sap a
toujours été le cas si vous avez déjà
tenté un petit peu de faire de la
géologie généalogie vous allez voir que
les registres de l'état civil commence
au 19e siècle et puis plus précédemment
enfin là de manière vraiment j'ai envie
de dire complète et puis vous allez
tomber sur des registres paroissiaux
donc plutôt c'était l'église qui actait
les naissances et les décès et puis
avant ça on était un petit peu dans les
limbes et il se passe est trop rien quoi
on n'avait vraiment pas d'idée de caen
jean quand les gens nés c'est quand les
gens décédés et donc c'était un peu
rock'n'roll et je dis souvent aux élèves
mais cette situation là c'est ce qui
existe encore dans certains pays où
l'état est totalement défaillant on peut
parler d'état faillite faillite state
dans ses étals à l'administration est
absent tout est corrompu ou s'en fout
complètement c'est un peu caricatural ce
que je dis mais j'essaie d'aller vite
oui bonjour spock imac rond et c'est
bien déclarés à l'élection
tout à fait et je te pardon goethe
accueil vraiment ici sur le chat puisque
c'est la première fois que tu poses une
question donc depuis rend vendredi mais
je n'ai pas tué anglophone tu poses la
question en anglais moi je vais pas
faire le stream en anglais voilà c'est
déjà compliqué en français donc depuis
vendredi les candidats à l'élection tout
à fait ouais mais là il a produit une
lettre on en reparlera si ça vous
intéresse et élections présidentielles
françaises il faut pas hésiter c'est
plutôt le mercredi et le jeudi qu'on en
parle voilà je vais te répondre quand
même dans le chat comme ça
alors par rapport à maquereau
ce qui est intéressant aussi de noter
c'est que ici j'ai vu un sondage où il
est à plus de 30 % donc ça c'est assez
intéressant mais ça on en parle mercredi
alors donc je disais mais voilà quand tu
as un état failli c'est assez difficile
finalement de de comptabiliser
correctement tous à mettre dans nos
états nous qui sont relativement bien
organisés au niveau de l'état civil là
tu vas pouvoir avoir un contrôle et une
comptabilisation des naissances des
décès assez précise et finalement pour
évaluer l'évolution de la population
puisque c'est ça la démographie ce la
science qui va s'intéresser à l'état de
la population en termes plutôt de
quantité j'ai envie de dire eh bien à ce
moment-là il te reste à comptabiliser
tous qui est migratoires et tu vas avoir
une idée si ta population diminue ou
augmente par rapport à un pays par
exemple et ainsi de suite
donc c'est ça qui est assez intéressant
ici c'est qu'on va faire le point sur
cette variable qui est moins bien
précise que ne l'est
la variation naturelle quoi les
naissances et les décès il est beaucoup
plus facile pour un responsable
politique de compter les mouvements
internationaux de chaussures ou de
téléphones portables que ce d'infirmier
ou d'ouvriers du bâtiment ce constat du
programme des nations unies pour le
développement dans son rapport annuel de
2009 demeure d'actualité en 2018
améliorer les données sur les migrations
internationales est encore affiché comme
le premier objectif du pacte mondial sur
les migrations adoptée par l'assemblée
générale des nations unies je vais
revenir sur certains thèmes je vais
vraiment lire tout le paragraphe cet
objectif vaut bien vaut aussi bien pour
les stocks que pour les flux selon la
terminologie des démographes les
premiers consiste en une comptabilité de
la population des immigrants à un moment
donné sur un territoire délimité plus
difficile à saisir les second porte sur
les mouvements et nécessite de mesurer à
la fois les entrées flux d'immigration
et les flux de sortie flux d'émigration
de chaque pays alors plusieurs choses
intéressantes surtout si vous débutez
dans les sciences sociales la première
chose tiens qu'est-ce que les nations
unies les nations unies l'organisation
internationale qui va regrouper
le plus de nation possible toutes les
nations on n'en sont pas membres parce
qu'il ya certaines conditions aussi en
termes de reconnaissance je pense est
ici tu as dans les nations unies
différents programmes ou pardon je vois
que
le l'article n'était plus afficher ça
arrive souvent je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
ma fenêtre qui parfois se disparaît et
réapparaît et j'ai pas encore identifié
l'élément qui fait qu'elle disparaît si
vous êtes plus doués que moi en obs nes
et n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que je
pouvais faire pour éviter que cette
fenêtre se désactive je sais pas
pourquoi ça ces actifs c'est très
désagréable parce que je m'en rends pas
compte toujours content alors regardez
ce que j'ai trouvé sur twitter ce qui
est assez sympa pour vous représenter ce
que sont les nations unies alors ici on
en a beaucoup parlé avec
la russie
les nations unies c'est pas forcément
que la grande conférence où on voit les
représentants de chaque pays où il va y
avoir parfois des agences ou des
programmes qui vont s'occuper d'un
domaine bien précis est ici par exemple
tu vois dans les fonds et programmes tu
as le nude le programme des nations
unies pour le développement qui va
s'intéresser comment faire pour que les
pays qui sont moins développés bien
puisse compenser le retard par rapport
aux pays dits développés évidemment et
donc tu as plusieurs choses qui existent
un tu connais sans doute unicef un le
fonds national le fonds des nations
unies pour l'enfance qui va par exemple
organiser des campagnes de prévention
des campagnes aussi de financement je me
suis bien ici a pas très longtemps suite
à un reportage tout à fait troublant
d'envoyé spécial sur la famille dans
madagascar j'ai été voir et je voyais
qu'il faisait des appels aux dons dont
par exemple
c'est un exemple de d'actions qu'ils
mettent en place donc voilà pour te dire
que les nations unies c'est quand même
un gros truc et qui regroupe vraiment
toute une galaxie de
d'organisation et de structure
par et paraétatiques
donc voilà ça c'est la première chose
qu'on peut dire donc ici les chiffres
viennent viennent principalement du pneu
mais on aura d'autres alors bien
distinguer quand tu parles de migration
des stocks c'est le nombre de personnes
qui sont sur ton territoire alors ici en
l'occurrence c'est le nombre de
personnes
issues de l'immigration qui sont sur ton
territoire où le nombre de personnes qui
ont la nationalité étrangère sur ton
territoire ça c'est ton stock et puis tu
as le flux 1 chaque année il ya des gens
qui arrivent et puis il ya des gens qui
repartent il faut pas aussi confondre
immigration et immigration c'est un truc
de base mais voilà quand tu veux faire
de la démographie faut surtout pas
confondre alors il ya un petit truc pour
pour savoir la différence entre les deux
est pas se tromper un convoi la con et
collégiens qu'on ait dit 'tiens qu'on
élève du secondaire c'est parfois
compliqué de distinguer les deux en fait
tu te référer au latin ou à l'anglais
tout ça insee dedans donc immigration tu
vois ça vient d'eux dans quoi in le i tu
vois de l'immigration c'est in et
émigration ses ex non latins ces ex
c'est hors d'eux quoi ex exilés
tu vois
exfiltré tu vois ça c'est dehors etc
sans donc voila tu as eu deux ex qui se
retrouvent dans l'immigration ça c'est
le petit truc mnémotechnique que tu peux
utiliser pour bien distinguer les deux
alors attention maintenant on va
s'attaquer à une confusion courante qui
est les termes étrangers immigrés et
immigrants c'est pas les mêmes choses et
ici on va faire le point là dessus
jusqu'au début des années 1990 ou 1990
les statistiques publiques françaises se
sont focalisés sur les personnes
étrangères c'est à dire dépourvu de la
nationalité française
ok donc retient bien étrange et c'est
qu'il n'a pas la nationalité du pays en
question ici la france
or puisque les personnes nées en france
ne sont pas automatiquement française
certains étrangers sur le territoire
n'ont en réalité jamais me grey alors si
on met par exemple le cas de la belgique
que je connais un peu mieux que la
réalité française bien en belgique tu
vas voir par exemple des personnes de
nationalité italienne mais qui sont nés
en belgique tout simplement parce
qu'elle prenne la nationalité italienne
de leurs parents et donc voilà tu es
peut être italien en belgique en n'ayant
jamais mis les pieds dans un autre pays
que la belgique voilà c'est ça que ça
veut dire après tu transpose ça et que
les nationalités que tu veux en sachant
que le droit pour acquérir la
nationalité va dépendre d'un pays à
l'autre
donc ça il faut voir quoi iliad est
peut-être début des nationalités je ne
sais pas j'ai passé en tête mais
peut-être nationalité que tu peux pas
avoir si tu ne réside pas dans le pays
je fais une hypothèse mais il faudrait
vérifier
évidemment s'il ya 200 pays à 200
deux cent façons d'acquérir la
nationalité différente voire plus parce
que dans un même pays tu peux avoir
différentes modalités
or puisque les personnes nées en france
ne sont pas automatiquement française
certains étrangers sur le territoire
n'ont en réalité jamais me grey par
ailleurs une personne immigrée peut
acquérir la nationalité du pays où elle
vit et alors quitté le contingent des
étrangers mais oui si tu es naturalisés
dans le la nationalité du pays dans
lequel tu vis tu vas être décomptées du
stock voilà tout simplement
et donc tu n'es plus étranger mais tu es
à peut-être migrer un jour
dans un souci d'amélioration de la
connaissance statistique du phénomène
migratoire les dirigeants de l'insee de
lynette et du haut conseil à
l'intégration ont conjointement
officialisé lusage de la catégorie
immigrés en 1991 sous 1991 1 et immigrés
une personne née étrangères à l'étranger
c'est-à-dire venir s'installer en france
pour un an au moins qu'elle ait acquis
ou non la nationalité française par la
suite voir l'encadré la catégorie
reposant à la fois sur le pays de
naissance et la nationalité à la
naissance permet de distinguer les
rapatrier des anciennes colonies nés à
l'étranger avec la nationalité française
d autres migrants oui voilà parce que
quand il y avait la ligue i française
battue à des gens qui naissait en
algérie qu'ils étaient français et puis
après qu'ils ont migré pour venir en
france ils n'étaient pas nés en france
tu veux donc tu peux avoir plein de
choses des réalités totalement
différentes qui brouille un peu les
pistes donc si tu fais pas bien tu es
définition et si tu te tiens pas bien
compte des définitions qui sont prises
dans les bases de données que tu
travailles tu peux faire de grosses
bêtises quand tu t'y à des conclusions
quoi c'est pour ça surtout enfin les
profs souvent il vous pose des questions
sur les définitions c'est pas par
plaisir de
démêlez définition c'est parce que les
définitions c'est la base d'un discours
scientifique si tu n'as pas bien défini
les termes tu ne sais pas si on parle de
la même chose donc au début d'un travail
est généralement tu dois dire quelle
définition tu utilises parce que voilà
on le voit bien ici un pour le terme
immigrés aux étrangers il ya plein de
définition qui existent en fonction des
pays en fonction des instituts qui ont
fait ça et donc si tu call pas au départ
a bien on fait du bullshit tout
simplement
la division de la population des nations
unies qui assemble les informations de
tous les pays du monde définit quant à
elle les migrants internationaux comme
des personnes qui résident dans un pays
différent de leur pays de naissance
quelle que soit leur nationalité actuel
ou à la naissance donc tu peux être nés
à l'étranger
avoir la nationalité par exemple de la
belgique
revenir en belgique a bien dans ici dans
la définition des nations unies a bien
tu es considéré à ce moment là comme un
immigré voilà ce qui ne sera pas le cas
forcément dans la définition qu'on a vu
de la france bien sûr le décompte des
migrants internationaux varie selon la
définition adoptée bah oui donc tu vas
avoir des chiffres différents parce que
souvent on entend c'est un peu un
discours populiste oui mais vous savez
les chiffres ya plein de chiffres
différents qui circulent c'est du
n'importe quoi et tout ça tout ça c'est
pour nous influencer mais non ça dépend
simplement ce qu'on a compté et tout ça
découle de la définition que l'on a fait
des catégories que l'on entend utiliser
c'est pour ça qu ici on est vraiment sur
un travail scientifique j insiste 1
c'est par ce travail de sur les
définitions
en 2019 au sein de l'ensemble de sa
population résidente la france compte 10
% d'immigrés selon la définition
française mais 13% selon la définition
internationale adoptée par l'onu ce qui
est normal puisque tu as ces fameux
français qui sont nés français dans des
anciennes colonies et puis après qui
sont venus en france donc pour les
nations unies ils sont immigrées tandis
que pour la france ils sont pas immigrés
sont français tout simplement
voilà alors icitap de trois ans car qui
encadraient qui sont intéressants ici on
te remettes toutes les définitions bon
comme l'article le petit je peux
m'amuser à tout lire selon la définition
internationale aux nuls individus qui
réside dans un pays différent de son
pays de naissance quelle que soit sa ou
ses nationalité on distingue les
immigrants des migrants ça c'est les
migrants international migrants on a
déjà dix étrangers individus qui ne
détient pas la nationalité du pays dans
lequel ils résident qu'ils soient qu'ils
y soient nés ou non immigrant j'en ai
déjà parlé
immigrés selon la définition française
individus nés hors de france avec une
autre nationalité que la nécessité
française autrement dit est immigré un
individu n'est étranger à l'étranger tu
vois la définition elle est différente
entre l'onu et la france sur ce point là
alors ici on en reparlera de ces
encadré ci mais je vais en parler tout
de suite je vous les expliquer on va
parler de partir de la figure 2
proportion d'immigrants en france et
dans ces pays voisins et donc tu vois
que la france est à 13% et là on est sur
la définition de l'onu oui de l'onu
en belgique on est à 10 7% alors là je
fais le lien par rapport à la campagne
présidentielle quand zemmour ou le pen
dit zahia beaucoup d'immigrés en france
où je sais pas ce qu'il dit c'est
exactement ça comme ça mais imaginons
qu'il le sous-entendent bien tu vois
qu'en france c'est pas plus qu'ailleurs
en tout cas après on est d'accord le
diable se cache dans les détails comme
on dit il faut voir un petit peu la
répartition quoi parce que si tu as un
luxembourgeois dans la tête de marine le
pen je pense que le luxembourgeois s'est
pas à l'étranger qui est problématique
est donc évidemment si c'est des
luxembourgeois qui en masse sont chez
toi
ça c'est une autre chose à considérer
m'enfin bon c'est pas notre propos ici
nous on s'en fout de ce à quoi
donc et tu vois que le luxembourg 47%
d'immigrants le jour on ferme les
frontières c'est compliqué pour
luxembourg qui apparemment a besoin
d'avoir une population étrangère parce
que après voilà pourquoi l'allemagne et
à 18% c'est parce qu'elle a besoin aussi
d'une population immigrée étant donné
que sa population diminue en fait
faut pas croire il ya des raisons aussi
regardez d'ailleurs ici
non c'est après on verra un autre
graphique confond les graphiques ici
c'est la différence que tu peux faire
entre les différentes définitions tu as
8 4 millions d'immigrants selon la
définition de l'onu en france mais tu en
as 1.7 millions qui sont nés français
des rapatriés ou des enfants d'expatriés
tu vois des gens qui étaient français
qui sont partis dont 10 enfants
l'étranger il il a lancé des françaises
l'enfant et puis revient en france
et tu à 6,7 millions d'immigrés selon la
définition française
voilà et 57,9 millions de nos migrants y
compris des descendants de migrants nés
sur le territoire français évidemment et
là tu pourras voir des étrangers dans
cela et d'ailleurs les voilà donc 0.7
million d'étrangers
et 6 4 2 millions d'étrangers
donc sûr c'est sur ces chiffres qui
datent de
tu as 4 9 millions d'étrangers donc
ouais on est à moins de 10% de
d'étrangers
en france
perspectives internationales sur les
stocks de migrants l'avantagent la
définition internationale des migrants
est qu'elle permet d'établir des
comparaisons entre pays la france se
situe seulement au 16e rang des pays
d'émigration dans l'europe des 28 en
2019 malgré l'ancienneté de son
immigration et les effets de la
décolonisation qui lui sont spécifiques
la part des immigrés en france se situe
à un niveau à peine supérieur à celui de
la moyenne européenne 12% loin derrière
son voisin allemand 18% le luxembourg
avec près de la moitié de sa population
née dans un autre pays
47 % est un cas particulier qui
illustrent la diversité des situations
en europe et le fait que les petits pays
accueille souvent une proportion plus
élevée de migrants que les grands pays
ce qui va toujours le cas parce que
regarde ici l'afld la belgique est
derrière l'allemagne or on est plus
petit que l'allemagne donc faut éviter
les généralités comme ça je pense après
ça dépend encore une fois question de
définition qu est ce qu on appelle un
petit pays
comptait les immigrants n'est pas le
plus difficile il s'agit de repérer dans
les recensements ou les registres de
population dans les pays qui en sont
dotés évidemment c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué au début du stream les
personnes nées à l'étranger en revanche
compter les immigrants d'un pays
c'est à dire les personnes qui ont
quitté son territoire est une tâche plus
ardue c'est seulement au tournant des
années 2000 que de grandes institutions
internationales comme la banque mondiale
les nations unies le cd l'organisation
de coopération de développement
économiques ont eu l'idée de rassembler
les recensements de pays différents pour
établir une statistique de l'immigration
par exemple pour connaître le stock des
immigrants de la france elle propose
d'additionner les personnes qui sont
nées et qui sont recensés dans tous les
autres pays du monde en pratique
l'opération est complexe elle requiert
d'assemblée et d'homogénéiser des
recensements du monde entier dont les
définitions les dates de réalisation
peuvent varier oui tout le monde ne
compte pas sa population en même temps
et donc tu peux avoir des décalages donc
tu connais jamais vraiment le nombre de
français à l'instant t c'est impossible
je parle de ceux en france à l'étranger
1 c'est impossible on peut ainsi estimer
en 2022 pour cent personnes nées en
france près de 4,4 pardon vivent dans un
pays étranger
ce ratio 1,7 ce rapport qui donne une
mesure de l'intensité de les migrations
internationales approche 6% pour
l'italie ou la belgique et 20% pour le
luxembourg la france est un pays où
l'importance relative de départ est
limitée par rapport à la moyenne
européenne près de 9 % l'intensité de
l'émigration il est cependant supérieure
à ce que l'on observe dans d'autres
régions du monde en moyenne en 2020 pour
cent personnes nées dans un pays
d'afrique trois ont changé de pays le
ratio valant 2 5% en asie et 1 5 en
amérique du nord voilà ce qu il y aussi
intéressant par rapport à la campagne
présidentielle
étant donné que marine le pen est là une
mesure qui qui propose de donner un
certain revenu je sais plus exactement
quoi un avantage financier quelconque
aux jeunes de moins de 30 ans et sa
justification les c'est parce qu'ils
partent à l'étranger mais tu vois qu'ici
évidemment on parle pas que des jeunes
c'est pour éviter ben je me suis mal
exprimé mais pardon c'est pour éviter on
leur donne ce montant là pour éviter
qu'ils aillent ailleurs refaire des
études et et pour qu'ils puissent rester
en france parce que la france a besoin
de ces jeunes donc ça c'est sa
justification on ici évidemment on a pas
que les jeunes mais il faudrait vérifier
est ce que la france a vraiment un tout
départ des jeunes important parce
qu'après c'est ce que c'est une mesure
nationale qui va contrecarrer une
tendance sociale profonde et je prends
un autre exemple pour que tu comprennes
bien
on le constate que des politiques
natalistes comment aux grilles ne
fonctionne pas donc hors balais son
gouvernement donc le responsable
politique hongrois veut donner de
l'argent veux veux comment dire
favoriser les naissances parce que la
hongrie est comme beaucoup de pays
européens un déficit
naturel de sa population et donc il veut
pousser les naissances de petites et de
petits endroits en donnant un certain
montant une certaine somme d'argent puis
les élèves souvent quand je leur
explique cette mesure ait dit ça mais
c'est une très bonne idée quoi je leur
dis parce que quoi parce qu'on va vous
donner je sais pas moi 500 euros vous
allez faire un enfant à 20 ans ah ben
non monsieur moi j'ai pas envie d'avoir
un enfant à 20 ans et donc tu vois que
c'est pas une question d'argent c'est
une tendance profonde de ne pas faire
d'enfant jeunes et d'en faire de moins
en moins c'est le sens de l'histoire
j'ai envie de dire même si c'est un peu
pompeux de dire ça mais c'est pareil ici
avec les gens qui s'en vont d'un pays
c'est les frontières sont ouvertes il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui ont envie
d'explorer le monde qui ont envie
d'aller ailleurs dans mon entourage
beaucoup de gens qui ont soit envie de
pédaler en france ou qui ont envie
d'aller au canada ou qui ont envie
d'aller aux états unis faire leur vie ou
un morceau de leur vie tout simplement
donc voilà c'est un peu ces mesures
c'est un peu je pense des coups d'épée
dans l'eau ça ne sert pas à grand chose
et tu vois qu'ici bas la france n'est
pas déconnante par rapport à son
immigration en tout cas
après mon analyse est très simpliste
mais c'est pour vous donner aussi des
idées comment comment développer les
thèmes qui sont qui sont ici
je formule plus des hypothèses que des
certitudes ça c'est une évidence le rôle
des migrations dans la croissance de la
population
comptabiliser les stocks de populations
migrantes ne renseignent pas sur les
mouvements de populations dans le temps
comment donc établir l'impact des
entrées et sorties de migrants sur la
croissance ou la décroissance de la
population d'un pays il faut calculer le
solde migratoire vous c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi la migration la migration
on est donc là j'ai souligné parce que
c'est un concept aussi qui est important
pour la démographie c'est la différence
entre le nombre de personnes entrées et
sorties sur une année dans son
territoire
généralement si tu as un solde
migratoire négatif
c'est pas très bon parce que ça veut
dire que les gens qui t'ont territoire
c'est ce que j'explique souvent aux
élèves en dernière année de secondaire
puisque on
on travaille sur les questions
d'aménagement du territoire et de
territoire mais à l'échelle parfois très
locale et quand je leur dis voilà en
france ou en belgique tu as des communes
dans lesquelles tout le monde s'en va
ouais c'est une fée un fait avéré les
jeunes s'en vont parce qu'il ya plus de
service il ya pas d'emplois et donc ton
territoire il meurt tout simplement pour
rappel ce qu'est un territoire c'est un
espace sur lequel vit une population
mais ton territoire il disparaît parce
que il ya plus de population où il ya
plus de décoder des personnes plus âgées
j'avais même eu écho d'un village en
france et c'est un truc que je répète
souvent parce que c'est vraiment un
exemple intéressant de village en france
dans lequel il n'y a plus personne et en
fait le maire c'est quelqu'un qui a une
résidence secondaire en fait tu n'as
plus que des résidences secondaires donc
des soldes migratoires négatifs ce n'est
pas très bon pour le dynamisme de ton
territoire parce que tu es personnes
âgées il faudra s'en occuper alors à
l'échelle d'une commune voilà on
comprend que ça va pas être tragique au
final si ce n'est pour la vie du village
mais pour un pays voilà c'est vraiment
il faudra trouver des solutions et donc
le vieillissement de la population c'est
un réel problème démographique
et voilà l'allemagne par exemple a pris
la décision de pallier cette diminution
démographique par de la migration tout
simplement
sinon qu'est ce qui se passe bien tu vas
devoir travailler beaucoup plus vieux et
je fais encore un lien avec la
présidentielle quand tu as certains
candidats qui vit dix qui disent ah mais
je veux que la retraite elle soit à 60
ans je pense que marine le pen elle est
aussi pour une retraite à c'est au jeu
plus ses 60 ans ou si elle veut
maintenir à 65 ans mais alors marine il
faudra qu'ils aient de la migration quoi
ça c'est des évident sinon bien tu vas
te retrouver comme le japon qui est un
pays où il ya très peu de migration et
où les gens travaillent très très tard
après tu as aussi d'autres variables
d'ajustement comme l'automatisation
ainsi tu as beaucoup de machines tu peux
avoir besoin de moins de personnes les
moi personnellement quand je serai une
personne âgée j'ai pas envie que ce soit
un robot qui s'occupent de moi ça c'est
une évidence
alors chacun son avis là dessus
donc on est ici sur le sol naturel solde
migratoire le solde naturel est inconnue
grâce aux données de l'état civil et la
variation de la population grâce
heureusement recensement successifs on
peut indirectement estimer le solde
migratoire par la différence donc le
solde naturel c'est les naissances
moins les décès
si c'est positif tu as eu plus de
naissances que de décès docta population
augmente et le solde migratoire c'est la
même chose en immigration quand tu
ajoutes au solde naturel et on solde
migratoire tu sais si tu as population
elle augmente où elles diminuent tout
simplement de manière globale que tu
soit étranger ou pas immigré ou pas
ça va si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas dans le chat pas de souci
cependant cette méthode résiduelles
demeure imparfaite car elle intègre dans
le solde migratoire les imprécisions de
recensement de l'état civil qui dans
certains pays est très déficient il est
donc plus prudent de parler de soldats
par an les soldes migratoires peuvent
être ré estimer plus précisément à
posteriori en incluant dans l'équation
démographique le solde naturel le solde
migratoire est là justement due aux
imprécisions du recensement rétablissant
ainsi la cohérence entre les sources
d'information statistique tu vois c'est
une fameuse tambouille un l'on mélange
différentes choses et c'est pas évident
évident d'avoir une certitude par
rapport aux chiffres
parce que si tu as des ressortissants
dans certains pays je sais pas qui ont
des problèmes de d'état civil ben voila
tu vas pas savoir forcément combien tu
as deux français dans ce pays là ô
combien de belges en speed
donc méfiez vous
toujours des statistiques en termes
démographiques se veut pas dire que ça
veut dire ça ne veut pas dire que c'est
du n'importe quoi je dis pas ça non plus
les démographes vous voyez les gens qui
font par exemple ce papier sont
évidemment des gens très sérieux et
rigoureux et donc il n'ya pas lieu de
dire que les chiffres sont vraiment très
très déco nord mais voilà pas non plus
considérer ça comme une précision
chirurgicale
les résultats de la figure 3 tiennent
dans les données recueillies par
eurostat donc et l'organisme statistique
de l'union européenne auprès des
instituts nationaux de statistiques
permettent un incident approximer la
contribution des migrations à la
croissance démographique dans les pays
de l'union européenne les résultats de
la figure 3 tiennent compte des premiers
deux premiers ajustements et sont encore
susceptibles d'être évalués dans la
période 2010-2019 en moyenne on estime
aujourd'hui que la population de la
france a crû chaque année de presque 4
personnes pour 1000 habitants ces trois
sets pour 1001 qu'elle a deux petits 0
c'est pour mes justice à parce que une
année un élève me dit monsieur il ya une
erreur ici c'est pas des % il ya 1 0 en
trop manon jc pour 1000 quoi ah ben
c'est intéressant de le savoir mais
avait-elle répondu l'essentiel de cet
accroissement est tendue au mouvement
naturel au contraire dans les autres
pays les migrations internationales sont
le principal facteur de la croissance
démographique
on va voir ça dans un super schéma la
supergrafx pardon qui est ici
donc en fait tu as
tout ce qui est en comment dire au
dessus de l'abc si si ça signifie que tu
es en augmentation donc tu vois que dans
tous les pays qui sont représentés ici
la population augmente mais tu vois
ensuite la différence avec le solde
migratoire à ben un dock c'est à dire le
solde migratoire plus ces ajustements et
le solde naturel donc en bleu c'est les
naissances et les décès de ton pays
enfin la différence entre les deux le
solde naturel est en rouge basse et
l'immigration les immigrations pardon -
les émigrations et tu vois tout de suite
que l'italie
allemagne la population augmente mais
uniquement grâce à la migration
et si tu n'as pas les flux migratoires à
bientôt et la population qui diminuerait
tu vois aussi et là c'est très
intéressant qu'en france par rapport aux
autres pays européens mais finalement il
n'y a pas tellement de migration quoi et
ça ça peut être intéressant bon
maintenant tu aurais moore qui te dirai
oui mais le dont le solde naturel ce
sont les familles qui sont issus de la
migration des pays afrique qui ont plus
d'enfants patati patata voilà corps sait
toujours comment dire
quand on veut tuer son chien on l'accusé
d'avoir la rage ça veut tout simplement
dire une fois que tu veux trouver une
raison de justification à ce que tu
proposes tu de la trouvera toujours
évidemment
donc très intéressant ce graphique
du coup je sais plus où j'en étais
ici je pense à comment faire la part des
entrées et des sorties dans le solde
migratoire répondre avec exactitude à
ces questions est difficile dans la
plupart des pays sinon impossible dans
beaucoup d'entre eux tant les sources
d'information sont rares ou lacunaire
en france deux sources renseignent sur
les flux d'immigration depuis que le
recensement repose sur des enquêtes
annuelles il permet d'estimer le nombre
des entrées grâce à des questions sur
l'année d'arrivée en france et le lieu
de résidence l'année précédente cette
source a théoriquement l'avantagent de
couvrir l'ensemble de la population
résidant sur le territoire mais
certaines personnes notamment les plus
récemment arrivées peuvent échapper aux
enquêtes de recensement elles peuvent
toutefois être comptabilisé
ultérieurement lorsqu'elles sont
finalement recensés l'autre source de
données est administrative provient du
ministère de l'intérieur l'application
de gestion des dossiers des
ressortissants étrangers en france
permet de comptabiliser chaque année les
personnes qui ont obtenu un premier
titre de séjour d'une durée d'au moins
un an par définition cette statistique
est partielle puisque n'y figurent pas
les personnes qui ne disposent pas d'un
titre de séjour
c'est le cas de la plupart des enfants
qui sauf exceptions sont dispensés de
l'obligation de ces démarches
administratives
c'est aussi le cas des ressortissants de
la suisse et de l'espace économique
européen et de l'espace économique
européen c'est pas l'union européenne
mais c'est l'union européenne avec
certains pays qui ont certains accords
privilégiés comme je pense par exemple à
l'islande ou la norvège
alors même que ces groupes d'origine
représentait près de la moitié des
arrivées en france en 2016 2017 enfin
par définition les personnes dites sans
papiers ne figure pas dans la base de
données de aj
dfl sont cependant comptabilisé
lorsqu'elles sont régularisés donc ça
c'est toujours le problème quand tu
parles de migration évidemment les
clandestins tu ne connais pas par
définition elles sont cependant
comptabilisé lorsqu'elles sont
régularisés ce qu'on vient de dire au
final compte tenu de leurs propriétés
ces deux sources d'information
recensement et à gdf
pardon fournissent logiquement des
résultats différents sur le nombre et
les caractéristiques des nouveaux
entrants par ailleurs les différences
dans les méthodes d'enregistrement
peuvent conduire à des écarts dans les
effectifs de population pourtant
coupable
les pays voisins de la france ont
également une double comptabilité des
flux d'immigration eurostat réunit la
mesure des flux d'entrée des flux pardon
telles qu'enregistrées par les instituts
nationaux de statistiques
d'après les recensements les registres
de la pop et de population le cd 11 à
semble par ailleurs les informations sur
les titres de séjour pour établir des
séries statistiques sur les immigrés dix
permanents qui reçoivent un permis de
résidence en principe renouvelables
indéfiniment dans les faits le
renouvellement est souvent conditionné
les deux sources présentes logiquement
des résultats différents mais dans tous
les cas la france est avec l'italie le
pays qui en proportion a reçu le moins
d'immigration d'immigrants en europe de
l'ouest en 2019
l'immigration parent pauvre des
statistiques démographiques
en réalité nul ne peut dire si une
entrée va dans les faits donné lieu à
une installation permanente
bénéficier d'un droit de séjour non
limitée n'oblige pas demeurer sur place
toutefois force est de reconnaître que
la mesure des départs est très difficile
dans la plupart des pays du monde la
france ne faisons pas exception les
appareils statistiques traduisent
l'intérêt bien supérieur d état pour les
individus qui entrent et résident sur
leur territoire plutôt que pour ceux qui
en sortent
certains pays cependant
notamment en europe du nord sont dotés
de registres de population qui
permettent de mesurer les migrations en
théorie toute personne est tenu de
déclarer non seulement son installation
mais aussi son départ mais souvent en
pratique moins de la moitié des sorties
sur déclaré c'est un fameux billet
commun
des données longitudinales collectées
sur un échantillon représentatif de la
population résidente offre une
alternative les principes et de suivre
les individus d'un panel dans le temps
et de considérer qu'une personne
émigrent lorsqu'elle disparaît de
l'échantillon sans autre raison
apparente des ces changements l'adresse
défaut de collecte ou
d'appariement
appliquée en france grâce à un rabat un
appariement partielle des recensements
successifs entre 1975 et 1999
cette méthode a permis d'estimer qu'un
quart à un tiers des immigrés présents à
un recensement avait quitté la métropole
après un séjour de sept à neuf ans cette
technique d'estimation n'est plus
possible depuis que le recensement la
population est devenu annuel et partiel
en revanche les enquêtes annuelles de
recensement permettent de déduire les
sorties du territoire en soustrayant les
entrées du solde migratoire en 2017 ce
sont ainsi deux cent quinze mille
personnes qui auraient quitté la france
dont près de 29 % d'immigrés et 71 1% de
non immigrés nous voilà ce qui est plus
que ta population donc en fait à
beaucoup de personnes qui ont migré
qui ont immigré et après qui émigrent
constituant une avance a par exemple les
candidats qui vouloir un discours fort
par rapport à l'immigration ne vont
jamais de le dire
constituant une avancée dans la
compréhension des flux migratoires ces
calculs reste toutefois dépendant de la
précision des mesures du solde est d
entrer d'autres sources administratives
renseigne de façon très partielle sur
les sorties du territoire pour les
étrangers il existe des statistiques
relatives aux éloignement forcé ou
retours aidés pour les français il
s'agit de donner consulaires de
l'enregistrement demeure néanmoins
facultatif et dépend fortement du
calendrier électoral
pour un usage éclairé des statistiques
migratoires on l'aura compris les
statistiques relatives aux migrations
internationales sont souvent imparfaite
si les stocks de migrants internationaux
sont relativement bien connu quand les
données censitaire sont disponibles les
mesures des flux d'immigration et encore
plus des migrations reste limité dans la
plupart des pays du monde en france des
progrès ont été réalisés ces dernières
années même si les estimations des flux
et du solde migratoire peuvent encore
être améliorés cependant les
statistiques disponibles permettent déjà
de relativiser le rôle des migrations
dans l'évolution de la population
si la france est historiquement un pays
d'accueil elle est devenue l'un des pays
de l'europe de l'ouest où l'immigration
est en proportion parmi les plus faibles
quelle que soit la mesure considérée il
ne faut pas oublier en outre que la
france est aussi un pays d'émigration
une partie significative de ces immigrés
quitte son territoire dans les années
qui suivent leur arrivée et ses propres
ressortissants sont de plus en plus
nombreux à immigrer aujourd'hui les
natifs de france et migrent plus
fréquemment que ceux d'asie ou d'afrique
mais moins que en europe comme on
l'avait dit tout à l'heure voilà je
trouve que c'est vraiment un article
intéressant dans le contexte actuel un
stade de novembre 2021
maintenant vous connaissez ce genre de
petit feuillet
ouais ça peut être vraiment intéressant
il y en a plusieurs
après il ya peut-être un système
d'abonnement dans lequel vous êtes tenus
au courant moi je peux le faire vous
pouvez le faire vire kern je parlerai
une fois de cairns plus en détails même
si vous êtes aux études supérieures vous
connaissez déjà kern et si vous êtes un
élève dans une des classes où on accourt
ensemble est bien là vous connaissez
aussi kern parce que je vous en parle
beaucoup souvent dans le kern tu peux
remettre un abonnement pour ce ce genre
de petit communication parce que même si
tu ne lis pas tout j'ai envie de dire si
le thème plus ou moins intéressés mais
je pense particulièrement à mes élèves
parfois cherche des définitions des
choses comme ça mais tu vois tu peux
prendre quelques définitions qui sont
mises dans les encadrés prendre un
graphique l'analyser pour ton port folio
et alors là ce moment là c'est vraiment
bingo quoi super super intéressant
population française devrait continuer
de vieilles éditions demi siècle trois
enfants pour tous en chine un tiers des
femmes d'asie de l'est resteront sans
enfant tu vois c'est assez intéressant
évidemment c'est que de la démographie
coin
les enfants après à l'épreuve du premier
film en vivres célibataires des idées
reçues aux expériences vécues super
intéressant quoi
je vous en proposerait parce que je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment vraiment
bien voilà bah on a quasi tenu une heure
pour faire ce petit article alors après
voilà c'est toujours l'exercice vous
savez en direct c'est toujours compliqué
de dire une heure précise de début de
reprise de fin surtout de fins bon il ya
une semaine ou deux on a fait deux
heures et demie de stream sur un article
qui parlait du décrochage scolaire ça a
été super intéressant donc voilà enfoncé
un peu plus court parfois c'est un peu
plus long les prochains rendez vous
n'oubliez pas mercredi on va se voir
pour
analyser le programme d'un candidat
alors j'hésite encore ça pouvait être
jab d'eau le candidat écologiste ou
mélenchon on verra ce sera l'un des deux
et jeudi c'est l'émission politique les
clés de la présidentielle où là on
répond à toutes les questions qu'on se
pose sur la présidentielle je propose
aussi un débrief du programme du
candidat ça sera celui qui aura été
retenue pour mercredi et ensuite il y a
aussi le dossier le dossier cette fois
ci je pense que je vais faire sur les
écarts des candidats ou les scores des
candidats au premier tour des
présidentielles c'est à dire regardez
depuis qu' à la vème république
le score des différents candidats qui a
fait le plus de
lait plus haut score ça m'intéresse
parce que voilà macron je voulais dire
il ya un sondage qui le donne à 30% je
trouve que c'est quand même important
même s'il ya eu plus par le passé mais
ici par rapport aux candidats et c'est
important dans le sens où il ya un gros
écart avec le suivant c'est surtout ça
qui est intéressant à 30% il ya beaucoup
de candidats qui y avait des intentions
de vote à ce niveau là mais l'écart me
semble important dont j'aimerais
vraiment objective et ça et comparer ça
avec les autres élections
présidentielles donc ça sera le dossier
on regarde évidemment tous les sondages
bon maintenant les parrainages c'est
fini
on sait qu'il ya douze candidats le
dernier qualifié cette et philippe
poutou
et puis on parle évidemment de
l'actualité de la présidentielle voilà
si ça peut vous intéresser mais bon j'ai
peur de ne pas rencontrer une certaine
demande
ça serait peut-être de regarder ensemble
des meetings en direct et de les
commenter mais voilà j'ai pas non plus
envie de passer tout mon temps pour pour
personne alors je regarde tout seul et
je me donne au calme à la commenter mais
ça s'il y avait des gens intéressés ça
il faut le dire et on pourrait faire ça
voilà je vous remercie d'être venu je
vous remercie de m'avoir écouté et je
vous dis à très bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo salut salut